when you're providing things you're
doing things it's so much easier when
you're done with the work to sit back
and enjoy than to spend a whole day
doing
[Music]
nothing come to me fishy fishy that's I
didn't no tomato no contact look at that
I caught leaves
today we're fishing down to a place
called The lat my wife assures me it's a
good place as a kid she used to go down
with her sister we eat a lot of fish
especially with the decline of the
caribou and we need some dog food we
need some people food this time of year
we have two kinds of fish there they're
she fish and there's the pike that are
out to get the she fish well I intend to
catch them both so yeah we'll see how
that goes why do we have to do
this so we can eat the fish if you don't
eat you go hungry you know when the
caribo are gone and the rabbits are gone
carigan are down just fish fishing is
still pretty good like hunting you like
to hunt for your family yeah you can
fish for your family you can get your
Anna fish you can get your mom fish you
get all your auntie fish you can get
your uncle some fish hope I get one I
hope so too chip and I decided to take
mu Kelly out fishing bringing the kid
out to spend the night camping is really
important while he's young so he'll want
to go back out there get more fish and
provide for his family
just cuz the fish aren't here right now
doesn't mean they won't be here later so
you can always try these holes again
another thing we can go put holes all
the way along there if we felt like
it could go a little bit further out
still yeah cuz I'm uh I got about that
much water between the ice oh I got one
oh oh she fish she fish she
[Laughter]
fish yes a whop it I got it already G
grandson here you trade me holes lucky
my a cat
one we're going to have fish for
dinner oh I got one he catch two of them
yeah here anna is a good fisher
woman no I I was just thinking oh I got
one again man three different holes at
that Je every
hole wow just go over here and bless
mine would you
wow she is fishing circles around us
literally look at this right around us
we got three fish down because of
myana got one what oh big one just need
a fish for
me oh I got one pullet man you guys I
got a ceiling oh me too oh me too look
at at that oh I got a pip too woohoo wow
two seelix at once what are you guys
doing I hope I get one grandson the
trick is not to let your line loose
always keep it tight like this look
tight and your fish won't get away
you'll learn
grandson oh I got
one big one bigger than all of them hey
r on
Carol oh she finally got got
one oh I got one keep going grandson
keep
going oh you got a fish
stick all right grant said come over
here I'll make a new hole for me come on
you could come fish where where you
could catch something come
on I I thought I could was just that
stick it's really important to um make
sure we keep trying till he catches the
fish and that way he'll get that feeling
of you know providing and that's very
important that he gets that if he wants
to be a hunter when he grows up I just
want to catch one
[Music]
fish